in the desert of gabileen just south of
luxor
meredith searches for evidence of
egypt's earliest death rights
she believes the myths that drove
egyptians to mummify their own bodies
had roots much earlier than ancient
egyptian civilization
prehistoric rock art depicting wildlife
suggests this area was once a sacred
place
in the 19th century
archaeologists identified it as a burial
ground
this is a desolate dry landscape
nothing much to see on the surface
but underneath these rocks and sand
there would have been prehistoric tombs
in 1896
an egyptologist from the british museum
received a tip-off of a momentous
discovery
buried under a thin layer of desert
debris
local farmers had found a mummified body
preserved in astonishing detail
on the upper arm tattoos of horned
animals were still visible
and from the head sprouted tufts of red
hair
earning this mummy its original nickname
ginger there was a puncture wound to the
left shoulder blade
and a fractured rib beneath
forensic analysis has revealed the body
is male
and over 5000 years old
but how is this body so perfectly
preserved
for meredith the evidence suggests the
man's mummification was not planned
instead
it was an accident of nature in this
photo i can see there's no bandages or
anything that would have preserved this
mummy so it would seem that this was not
an intentional mummification
he was preserved by the sand
there was no ritual or magic or anything
involved
just the drying power of nature
hundreds of years before the first
pharaoh
this man lived around the fertile
floodplains along the river nile
but around his 20th birthday he was
brutally stabbed in the back
and left for dead
he was buried in a shallow grave with
simple clay grave goods and covered with
sand
but the desert sun and hot dry sand
quickly evaporated all the water from
his body
stopping it from decomposing freezing
him in time until his discovery
5400 years later
archaeologists have found no papyri that
explained the historical origins of
mummification but meredith believes the
practice could have evolved from
accidents of nature natural mummies like
the gabilee man would have inspired
ancient egyptians that if they could use
technology to harness the power of
nature their bodies too could last
forever into eternity
it's a truly spectacular discovery
it tells us where mummification started
[Music]
you